in epithelial sheet the cells are
connected to each other via cell
junctions and these cell junctions are
of different types like adherence
Junction gap Junction tight Junction in
each of these type of junctions has
their own functions but a combination of
these junctions ensures that whenever we
experience some kind of mechanical
stress the cell junctions and their
coordination with cytoskeleton element
prevents any kind of cellular distortion
upon encountering mechanical stress
otherwise upon experiencing extreme
stretch our epithelial would rupture but
that doesn't happen thanks to this kind
of cell Junction elements and
cytoskeletal proteins so in this video
we are going to talk about one type of
cell junction proteins and one type of
cell Junction components known as the
tight Junction the epithelial cell is
lying on the basal lamina and they are
connected to each other via several kind
of junctions and this installment we are
going to focus on the tight Junction
proteins so let's look at what tight
Junction is so the tight junctions are
strategically localized more towards the
apical side of the cell now if you
consider any epithelial cells they are
pretty much polarized that means they
have a apical and a basal lateral side I
mean you can simply think it in terms of
the top of the cell or the bottom of the
cell I mean the bottom and the top are
pretty much different from each other
but these tight Junction components are
made mainly localized very near to the
top surface or the apical surface I
would say and in the basal lateral side
you would find the adherence Junction
but we have focused on the tight
Junction components today now let's see
where does I mean which kind of roll
tide Junction plays in terms of cellular
physiology before that if we look at
look at from the side view the two cells
are kind of like stitched to each other
with the help of these tight junctions
so tight Junction pretty much works like
a permeability barrier only selective
molecules can pass through this barrier
and small substance like even many
solutes can not pass
and this selectively selectivity barrier
is very important for cellular
physiology not only that it works like a
barrier for intermingling of ion
channels or protein which are owns on
the membrane so ion channels have n
proteins or carriers these are present
on the plasma membrane and they are
pretty much dynamic they are floating
like a free island right or like a free
iceberg in the sea but since these kind
of barrier mechanisms are there the
apical proteins here in pink or blue
cannot go towards the basolateral side
and intermingle with the basolateral
protein so partitioning based on these
kind of junctions are possible inside
the cell and it has implications in
terms of cell signal transduction and
many others physiological processes now
let's look at our gut inside our gut in
the intestinal epithelium you would see
the epithelial cells are connected to
each other by tight junctions main
testable lumen if you look at the cell
types they are pretty much
interconnected by tight junctions that
ensures whatever the fluid is present in
my intestinal lumen or along with the
fluid there would be metabolites and
toxic substances anything cannot move
through this epithelial barrier and move
to the blood vessels or secrete their
content in the blood vessel so anything
that has to get inside the industry
lipid tinium or get absorbed in my
intestine like many food material or
many amino acids glucose etc it has to
pass through specific transporter in
this particular example glucose has to
pass through a gel t or sodium dependent
glucose transporter and tight Junction
ensures it cannot leak into the blood
stream but it has to pass through a
transporter and that is the importance
another important such epithelia is
present in the kidney the renal tubules
right the result abuse has many of these
tie junction proteins which ensures that
not even ions can pass through these
Junction and leak out into the blood
stream now inside our brain
several I mean inside our brain there
are several in neurons and glia and the
brain is kind of encapsulated with blood
vessels
now this blood vessel supply oxygen to
the brain right and these blood vessels
ensures that only selective molecules
can enter from blood to the brain and
brain needs some important molecules
such as oxygen glucose etc which can
readily plug cross this barrier but this
particular blood-brain barrier which is
present in the endothelial cell level or
the junctions present domaine both heal
cells of the blood vessels
they ensure toxic substances such as
toxic metabolite pathogens etc cannot
enter the Bloods cannot enter the brain
and they fail to cross the blood-brain
barrier and that is why blood-brain
barrier is very important apart from
blood-brain barrier our brain is
surrounded our brain is taking a bath
inside the cerebrospinal fluid and
choroid plexus which is lining the
ventricular cavity is the key source of
the cerebrospinal fluid colloid plexus
epithelial cells also also work like a
filter or a molecular sieve which
ensures harmful substances from the
blood cannot reach the CSF again there
is a barrier between the CSF and the
blood which is the blood CSF barrier and
the key component of the blood CSF
barrier is the tight Junction again and
these tight Junction ensures anything
that is presenting the blood cannot
enter the CSF and many substances in the
blood like many toxic metabolites are
thereby not entering the brain via this
route but important substances like like
ions and etcetera can pass through via
carriers let's look at the components of
the tight Junction in the context of
blood CSF barrier it's just a context
but overall this kind of tide Junction
protein a molecular aspect is pretty
much conserved throughout what brain
barrier blood CSF barrier or any kind of
epithelial barrier we might talk about
so the key components are occluding and
Claud
these two proteins they are for their
transmembrane proteins having four
transmembrane region and loop regions
outside which are intertwined to each
other just like they are stitching the
membrane together and there is important
adapter proteins such as so one and so
two which connects these clotting and
uploading anchors to the cytoskeleton
element in this case actin it ensures
further stability and firmness also
there are Junction associated molecules
or jams which helps the two epithelial
cell to be close enough to each other
such that molecules small molecules
cannot even diffuse now it has been
shown including mutant mice where
clotting production is inhibited or
clotting is eliminated there is no tie
junction in the epithelial barrier of
the skin as a result there is immense
amount of evaporation taking place from
the skin and the pup dies in early age
due to this that means Claudine
occluding present in the tight Junction
is super important for for ensuring that
fluid passage happens in a directed and
a controlled fashion
in case of CSF what we have seen let's
say the bicarbonate the chloride the
sodium potassium etcetera ion which need
to be secreted into the CSF only can
pass through specific transporters or
specific carriers present in the apt in
the apical and the basal lateral side of
the choroid epithelia because there are
tight junctions connecting these
epithelial cells so the blood bone
substances cannot directly diffuse and
enter the CSF it has to go through a
selectivity filter and that is how tight
Junction components are very important
for epithelia especially those epithelia
which works like an selectivity filter
such as in this video we have seen
blood-brain barrier and let CSF barrier
and also the barrier in the renal
tubules are in intestine and that is how
tight Junction is so important in terms
of cell physiology and the basic
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share subscribe
thank you